[Music]
sounds like you can't base any theories
of the genetics because it's all
interbreeding here and there so you just
have percentages and you don't know how
those percentages ended up there well
let me let me talk a little bit about
that those percentages this is how they
play with numbers and again this is more
politics than it has to do with science
science you would think genetics is
objective you know you would say oh yeah
genetics doesn't lie you know it's
mathematically perfect correct exact
right exactly but in the ballpark as
well no no it's got to be exact because
if I count you know somebody I've had so
many DNA strings or so many atoms I mean
you may want to take to the atomic level
let's count atoms and we say only to
specimen you have to do it across mates
business that's one issue but but let's
assume you finally concluded that you've
got all these all these strains well you
have you match the string you say well
yeah there's there's a 2% or 4% of 10%
match because you just look at the
strings and that part is objective or
these should be but it's not you see how
they play with the numbers here screen
2010 this is on the seminal paper on the
genome right the actual amount of
interbreeding between Nano 2000 modern
humans may have been limited given that
it contributed only 1 to 4 percent of
the genome of present-day non-africans
that's in 2010 here's them this is the
same group again some other people are
in there prefer 2014 using the high
coverage Neanderthal genome in
conjunction with the two other namaka
genomes we now estimate that the
proportion of nanos all derived DNA
people outside Africa is one point five
to two point one so we went from one to
four to one point five to two point one
it used to be four percent now we cut it
in half the two percent how can they
make such a big error that's a bigger
that's 50% and you think that stops you
know here here I have another case
because if they want to show that the
Nano those that humans lost a lot of the
DNA over the years that's how he ended
up with 2% you know we we had a lot more
in the past and here's an article that
didn't idea
it comes from Harrison Nielsen 2016 and
this is quoted by newswise magazine that
quotes them essentially assists today
yeah the thought sequences make up
approximately two percent of the genome
and people from non-african out
populations but Harrison Nielsen
estimate that at the time of
interbreeding long time ago closer to 10
percent of the human migrants genome
would have been and athough because
there were around 10 times more humans
and Neanderthals this number is
consistent with the two groups acting as
a single population that interbred at
random recent DNA evidence has confirmed
that the Neanderthal contributions the
eurasian genomes was higher in the past
here's the Smithsonian 2016 along the
same lines they don't go into numbers
but they give you a qualitative they
said you know evaluation the mutations
human of humans acquired from Nano those
are slowly being purged from the genome
over time much of their DNA would be
left behind during natural selection
what is the problem with all this the
problem is that they find a human
skeleton in Siberia
it's a forty-five thousand year old
Siberian man you know human man a
skeleton and this is what they say and
listen to this we present the high
quality genome they do a full genome on
this guy right we present the high
quality genome sequence of a forty-five
thousand year old modern human male from
Siberia we estimate that the the
proportion of Navajo admitster in the
hood issue individual that's of the
place to be 2 point 3 plus or minus 0.3
percent similar to present-day East
Asians and present-day Europeans in
other words here there the the
prediction was that in the old days they
had to have 10% and over time we lost a
lot of handle called DNA
ended up with only 2% they find this guy
this human in Siberia easy to get the
same 2% that we do and he had at forty
five thousand years ago when supposedly
the Ananda thugs were still around and
to make matters worse we have another
study that just throws a bucket of water
and the whole thing you know cold water
and the whole thing says lossy 2014 our
analysis reveals strong support for
Neanderthal admixture and Eurasia at a
higher rate three point four to seven
point three percent then suggested
previously using analysis and
simulations we show that our inference
is more powerful than previous summary
statistics and robust to realistic
levels of recombination in other words
they start out they say humans have
between one and four percent that was
the original paper that made modifies
mmm not really you know we can't
exaggerate we you know we boasted too
much we really only have two percent
never thought DNA and we ended up with
two percent because we originally had
like 10 percent 15 years ago over the
years we lost him you ended up with 2
percent so that's the logic these guys
come on and say well we found this this
human in Siberia he's only got 2 percent
just like we do and he's 45 thousand
years old and then these other guys come
and say oh by the way you know today we
don't have 2 percent we have 3 to 7
percent today we have 3 yeah so so we
start it up let's let's go over them we
started out with what the forward
percent that's what the first guy said
and this is remember this is genetics
perfectly accurate exact science right
so they say was 1 to 4 percent then they
said well and that really it's only 2
percent then they find a human that had
2% 45,000 years ago just the same as
what we have today and then these guys
do a new study another study and they
say oh by the way you know we have up to
7 percent
yeah no DNA is so how did we end up how
did how did the Siberian man have 2% in
the old days 45,000 years ago and today
we ended up with 7 percent according to
lasse
well it shows you that it's not an exact
science and these guys are just giving
you their opinions whatever they're
doing in those labs it's not objective
it's subjective they're just trying to
prove it mixture at all costs and
they're just playing around with the
numbers and here's oh here's the
punchline you know on this Wang 2012
okay
he doesn't analysis or he he essentially
quotes in two studies and these are done
these two studies were done by
geneticists right and they end up with
opposite conclusions over the over you
know they did say mitochondrial DNA in
this case study and Dana with different
conclusions gives you something to think
about in regards to geneticists neuen
estimated the nano thousand modern
humans diverts seven hundred six
thousand years ago
thus supporting the earlier conclusion
of nano thil negligible DNA contribution
to the modern european gene pool in
contrast we calculated the average
sequence divergence time between nano
cells and modern humans as five hundred
and sixteen thousand years ago and
finally consider a level of admixture
between annuals and modern humans so one
guy ends up with seven hundred thousand
years ago that's the point where we had
a common ancestor the other guy ends up
with five hundred thousand years there's
two hundred thousand years difference
that's the first one this guy ends up
saying there's no commonality with the
Nano thought or very little and this guy
says oh yeah we had all kinds of sex
with them and we are their offspring so
here you have these they end up with of
all different kinds of conclusions this
but they do the similar types of
analysis on samples so this gives you an
idea you know that you can't trust the
geneticists for the conclusion they're
reaching you know you can trust another
genders as far as you can throw on the
you know people can do is offer opinions
they can count they can count you know
strands of DNA they can do that that's
objective but their interpretation of
that data that's subjective and what and
the problem out there is that people
believe that a geneticist
they're infallible because you know they
they counted subjective it's
mathematical it's exactly
why should we dump them yeah the the
date of the the sample is its objective
but their interpretation of that date of
their analysis that's what's not
objective if there's twenty three
whatever matches they can count how many
matches there are but they can't infer
what those matches means right or why we
have that many matches yeah that's a
personal interpretation
these guys are lab boys that's all you
know they're lab technicians that's all
they are they're not theorists at least
they're not expert theories they're what
they're trying to do is accommodate
their theory with a current with a with
a rising current in pallet Nando's in
the end earth or paleontology which is a
mixture so they say oh all these guys
are fanatic about it mixture let's give
them proof and then they're coming out
with a time fitting into - the theory -
just a show just to become popular to
get funds and you know all this stuff
sounds like forensics where you can
state out the facts as detailed as you
need them as objectively as you have
them but what to make of those facts are
a different issue entirely that's left
up to the lawyer and the lawyer that's
the theory you guys produce the facts
and this is something similar here these
guys are acting as lawyers not not a
scientist
Booga so what do you think to the geese
that work at the Max Planck Institute
let me tell you what I think
[Music]